be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Jonathan Hickman's
Thor and the reason why I want to do
this is because I've never really done
anything on the Ultimate Universe before
we've dabbled we have run over Miles
Morales but for the most part I've never
actually had a reasonable discussion or
anywhere near as reasonable of a
discussion as I've had on all my other
videos and so what I want to do with
this because it's just a four-part
limited series is I want to run this in
the same capacity as our discussions on
Hickman's Fantastic Four where they're
basically back up videos to everything
else that I have going on on my channel
but I also want to use this as a testbed
to see whether or not there is any
interest in something that's ultimate
universe related for those of you guys
who don't know the Ultimate Universe was
effectively a reimagining of Marvel's
traditional comic book universe of
course Marvel's main comic book universe
dates all the way back to a Captain
America in the 1940s during World War
two and there was about a 20-year spurt
where they kind of had some waxes and
wanes and some adjustments and so on but
the fact remains that by the time the
1960s came around Marvel had a whole
bunch of different characters he had
spider-man he had the Fantastic Four the
x-men the Avengers Thor The Incredible
Hulk Iron Man the list goes on and on
and on but because of that huge surge in
popularity Marvel's comics exploded into
success but the issue here was that for
the next you know 30 years going into I
guess really the next 40 years going
into the year 2000 Marvel had all
different kinds of retcons and there
were a lot of things that got changed by
different writers who either had none of
the interest or the time to go back and
read through all that history and make
sure things matched up and so the result
was that readers were just kind of left
to their own devices to figure things
out you were left to your own devices to
figure out spider-man's timeline you
were left to your own devices to figure
out where Captain America fit into the
Marvel landscape and how everything you
know the progression of time happened in
Marvel Comics and so under Brian Michael
Bendis in the year 2000 Marvel sort of I
guess created an alternate reality so to
speak you know the ultimate ultimate
universe which is more of a streamlined
updated depiction of what Marvel
characters would look like if they
existed in the modern day and it was
done for modern readers for younger
readers and so John
and Hickman's Thor actually gives us the
backstory because in the end the
ultimate universe Thor was just kind of
there there hadn't really been a tried
and true origin to his character and so
this is what this is what hickman did
hickman basically in this four-part
series gives us the origin of Thor it
gives us everything that led up to the
massive event The Ultimates and how it
was that Thor was sort of rolled into
the ultimate universe and so what hitman
does here is he basically runs from
three different time periods he runs
from the early history of Thor's life
long before he ever showed up on earth
then it picks up in World War two and
then it jumps to the current moment the
modern day in the alternate universe and
so what we do here is we pick up in the
order point in time and what's happening
is Thor is basically telling us that
there are signs here there are readings
for those individuals who are paying
attention that Ragnarok is coming or
Ragnarok has occurred now for those of
you guys who don't know in Marvel Comics
Ragnarok is kind of like the end times
for Thor it is the end of the world is
it's the apocalypse for as Guardians now
I won't go into too much detail in terms
of how Ragnarok works in the Ultimate
Universe versus the main Marvel Universe
because that's a huge discussion in and
of itself but the fact remains that this
is basically the destruction of Asgard
and this is what Thor seen Thor seeing
that that Asgard has been completely and
totally obliterated that everybody is
dead that Balder is dead one of his
closest allies and friends that that the
the crows of Odin his eyes and ears you
know for the world that they're all dead
everything is effectively completely
destroyed but more so than that it's
being destroyed by an attack from the
combined forces of the frost giants and
the Nazis and this is really what makes
the story sort of interesting because
Hickman chose to invoke the Nazis into
this which is weird to me it's actually
kind of a strange situation but the fact
remains here that what we do is we
actually jump back to the current day
and we pick up in Brussels and and what
this does is it gives us a little bit of
injection on how things are different in
the Ultimate Universe versus the
traditional Marvel Universe and so for
those of you guys that never read
Ultimate Universe but you're very
familiar with earth-616
I'm going to go through here and sort of
provide some comparing contrasting and
what we're seeing the first is that of
course we have Brian Braddock and we
have his father in the main earth-616
universe Brian Braddock is Captain
Britain he's a superhero with the Amulet
of
- I can simulate a miter the emulative
right but it basically has a magical
amulet that grants him a force field
flight super strength durability things
like that your run-of-the-mill powers
when it comes to superheroes um but he's
not like he is here and this he's more
or less working alongside his father now
he is still a superhero but he's not
really a scientist and the main
earth-616 universe here he is but in
addition to this we find out that Brian
Braddock's father is actually working on
Europe's version of the Super Soldier
Serum now this is where the Ultimate
Universe differs from the main earth-616
universe in earth-616 Captain America
was the first successful test subject of
project rebirth of the Super Soldier
serum under weapons Plus which was under
sublime in the Ultimate Universe Nick
Fury was the first successful test
subject and because Nick Fury had been
successful the United States had turned
his attention to Steve Rogers and Steve
Rogers was given the Super Soldier Serum
under the idea that a time would come
where the world would need super
soldiers to fight on behalf of the
United States against whatever threats
may exist out there now this is where
everything starts to streamline because
what Brian Michael Bendis did and what
Marvel did is they tied everything to
the Super Soldier Serum with regards to
Wolverine for example because the US
Super Soldier Serum or super soldier
product on a project had been so
successful Canada wanted a project of
their own and so they took Logan they
took Wolverine and they basically put
him through the Super Soldier process
but while this was happening dr. Abraham
Cornelius came to the realization that
within Wolverine were genes that if
activated would bestow him with a litany
of different powers would basically wake
up powers in his body
and so what Cornelius did is he
basically took this these genes and he
dispersed them around the world and the
result was that mutants came into
existence now Marvel does not tell us if
these genes were already inside people
and were simply woken up or if the genes
were added to them Marvel simply just
says Wolverine is the origin of
and the ultimate universe and so this
it's really kind of a quagmire there at
least as far as I know for those of you
guys who are aware of whether or not
Marvel has told us that feel free to
post a comment below I don't want people
to be confused or to think I'm giving
bad information but but the fact remains
that that transitioning away from
rockets are continuing on with Captain
Britain with Brian Braddock and his
father we eventually realized that
they're basically dealing with some
individual they're dealing with some man
which of course we know is Thor simply
just because the fact of the story is
based on him but the fact remains that
in their different discussions in their
their studies with Thor they basically
can't understand what it is that he's
writing he's he's carving out some kind
of a language that they can't grasp and
so what they've done is they brought in
a scientist who has dabbled in
linguistics but is considered one of the
smartest man on the planet and this
person is revealed to be dr. Donald
Blake now again for those of you guys
who are familiar with earth-616 you're
aware that with Thor's history and the
6-1-6 universe that after he was cast
out of Asgard his mind was placed in the
body of Donald Blake and this was the
dichotomy of the Donald Blake Thor
history in the early days of Marvel
Comics Donald Blake he basically
stumbled across the the hammer of Thor
which to him looked like a cane he was
frustrated he hit it on the ground and
it turned into the hammer and that was
the early basis behind Thor stories
whenever he wanted to fight crime he
would hit the cane on the ground it
would turn into the hammer he would
become Thor and then he would fight and
then he would basically go back to being
Donald Blake again but in the ultimate
universe that's not the case there are
two distinctly different individuals and
this makes sense just because the whole
dichotomy earlier in the in the history
of Marvel was very confusing to people
but the fact remains that after
observing what it is a Thor's writing
when Donald Blake goes in there and
Donald Blake begins to to speak with
Thor the initial idea from Thor is that
this is just another guy who's there to
analyze him to psychoanalyze him to
basically kind of figure out what's
what's going on but at the same time he
also offers a little bit of information
here what Thor says is that he is
actually four of Asgardian
or of Norwegian myth the Norwegian
religion Thor the son of Odin but he's
basically leading Brian Braddock and his
father in EE
that he's crazy that he's an insane
person now why it is that he's doing
this as something we'll find out
relatively soon but the fact remains
that with with this character with
Donald Blake he's able to read this
Norse or this Asgardian language he's
able to read what it is
the Thor is writing and when Thor asked
him what he says Donald Blake says a
storm is coming and so what we do is we
actually jump back to World War Two and
we pick up with with the Nazis we pick
up with Adolf Hitler and Adolf Hitler is
a post by a man named Baron Zemo now
again this is where things really begin
to break away because in Marvel Comics
and in the earth-616 universe Baron Zemo
was is well known as the the father of
hell muse emo and he is the guy who
basically put Bucky Barnes in Captain
America in a situation whereby a plane
exploded
Captain America fell he was frozen and
ice and Bucky barn was taken by the
Russians and transformed into the Winter
Soldier
he was the catalyst for why it was that
Steve Rogers vanished off the face of
the earth for 20 years and this story is
a whole different kettle of beans and
we're actually gonna find out what's
going on with this as things begin to
progress even further but what happens
is he'll muse emo meets with I'm sorry
this is uh this is Tim were not not
Adolf Hitler I'm sorry guys
amigo that with Heinrich Himmler the
leader of the SS and what he basically
saying is that as the head of Hitler's
Gestapo as a head of Hitler's secret
police that he is in possession or at
least uh he'll muse emo is in possession
of these runes he's Asgardian runes now
this is very important and what Hickman
is actually doing is playing on
real-world history something that a lot
of people don't know is that while
Hitler was working to to attempt to
conquer the world effectively and
initiate the thousand-year Reich or the
Third Reich he was also obsessed with
myth and legend and Hitler really did
have various groups traveling throughout
the world trying to find artifacts that
were supposedly true supposedly real of
course uh Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade is based famously on the idea
that Hitler was trying to find the
goblet whatever it was that that Jesus
drank out of during the Last Supper
there supposedly provided eternal youth
um Hitler was searching for these things
this is what Hickman does he brings in
these real world concepts into the story
now of course this ties in a scar
it's hide under the comic book realm but
it still hits on the notion that Hitler
is very much obsessed with with myth and
legend anything that can basically grant
him absolutely power and guarantee his
success an elevation of position of a
God and so presenting these two up to
Heinrich Himmler of course Baron Zemo
says says you know Heil Heil Hitler and
so what we do here is we jump back to
Asgard which hickman only tells us as
eons ago but we can assume thousands of
thousands of years ago and what we do is
we picked up with Loki and we pick up
with Thor now what they're doing here
alongside Balder is they're just sort of
getting involved in their own their own
escapades fighting against the frost
giants but this is Hickman setting the
stage and boulder's someone I'd like you
to keep in the back of your head because
he will become very important in our
next discussion but with with Loki and
Balder and Thor going against the frost
giant it's not anything extremely
important with what they're doing when
you're somewhere just them being as
guardians they're just fighting frost
giants and you know being awesome doing
cool stuff a little bit of cautery
different things like that and so once
this what's this battle seems to be over
initially the idea is that they're going
to simply go back and celebrate but this
is not the case this is not actually
what happens while they are enjoying
themselves while they are celebrating
their camaraderie at the same time Odin
is having the hammer of Mjolnir
commissioned and with the hammer of
Mjolnir of course as we're going to
learn things are going to be very
different from what you guys are used to
in an earth 6-1-6 the hammer Mjolnir is
Thor's main hammer is his main weapon it
has an enchantments that belong to that
were put there by own but in your 6-1-6
universe is gonna be a little bit
different I'm trying I'm trying to sort
of walk on eggshells here I'm try not to
give too many things away um because
it's very easy to do especially with
this being such a short series it's not
drawn out like it's Fantastic Four we
can't just kind of not worry about those
sorts of things but what we do is we
transition back to back to northern
Germany in 1939 and of course we have
Baron Zemo and we have these various
guys who are getting together and he's
sort of you know showing them around and
he's taking them to these different
artifacts and so on but once he actually
activates one of these artifacts once he
begins the activation sequence what he
says is that if the if the United States
or if I'm sorry if Germany is going to
take over the world with regards to to
world war two you if they're going to be
successful in doing that they need
allies and so what happens it's just
basically opens up a portal and what
this does is it opens a portal up to the
realm of the frost giants
so what having said um I know this is
kind of a rough one it's not really the
same it doesn't really seem to flow the
same way as a fantastic four which I
understand Fantastic Four was a lot more
drawn out there was a lot more pacing
that was going on there
um but things are gonna start up sort of
makes sense they're gonna make sense
pretty fast within the next few issues
or so so bear with me guys feel free to
post any questions you have down in the
description I'll do my tour down in the
comments I'll do my best to answer them
without spoiling anything and yeah let
me know what you guys think about this
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you